At this point, you should be getting
a correctly formatted URL for
text and lat-long searches.
Let's go ahead and complete
the next steps to make the request.
We'll create a constant for
the shared NSURLSession, and
then we need to create an NSURLRequest
from our URL that's being created
by that flickrURLFromParameters method.
There we go.
After this,
let's create a data task using NSURL
sessions data task with request method.
Remember, this method let's us provide
a closer called a completion handler
that'll be executed when
the task completes.
For now let's just print the raw
data if no error occurs,
otherwise let's print some
information about the error.
And then the last step is to start this
task by calling its resume method.
Now let's make sure everything works.
And we see the raw JSON data's being
printed, and there's no error.
That's a good start.